everyone knows that inflation is only
getting worse and worse we now have the
highest inflation we've had in over 40
years recently came in at 7.9 percent
that means that all consumer goods that
are included in the consumer price index
cost almost 8 more this year than they
did last year this obviously means that
prices continue to rise but some
companies they don't want to play that
game they say rather than actually
increasing the price for the same amount
of goods what if instead we keep the
price the same and we simply reduce the
size of our products this isn't known as
inflation it's actually known as
something called shrink flation and it
is going wild right now across grocery
stores so if we go ahead and we take a
look this gatorade bottle itself is a
great example gatorade used to have a 32
ounce bottle on the left but now the
bottle is 28 ounces for the same exact
price that's the equivalent of a 14
price increase now if we go ahead and we
look at other goods you can see that the
bounty used to have 165 sheets now it
only has 147. if you look at something
like toothpaste used to be 4.1 ounces
now it's only 3.8 ounces doritos 9.75
ounces now just 9.25 ounces they
literally took five chips out of the
dorito bags and then wheat thins also 28
fewer crackers going into every single
one of their boxes this my friends is a
classic example of shrink flation they
keep the same exact price but they give
you less and less and less of the exact
same goods that is a form of price
increase and if you go down this list
you can see everything from ziploc bags
to bounty to gatorade to various other
goods and services we are watching
shrink flation take over grocery stores
for all sorts of different types of
consumer goods we also have this quote
right here that explains it pretty well
doritos simply saying inflation is
hitting everyone we took just a little
bit out of the bag so we can give you
the same price and you can keep enjoying
your chips well that little bit out of
the bag is another form of inflation
shrink flation is taking over and then
last but not least we have the febreze
bottle this bottle of febreze first time
it was purchased recently but if you
compare it to the old bottle the new one
is 37.5 percent smaller inflation is
ravaging america and also many economies
around the world whether they're
increasing the price for the same goods
or they're simply decreasing the amount
of goods you get for the same price it's
all a form of eroding your wealth away
it's time to get educated it's time to
start learning what you can do to
protect yourself hey you did you like
this video great we make five of them a
day and post them here on this channel
make sure you subscribe like the video
and see you next time